denn das virus jetzt schon da ist oder
scanner jetzt wo wir mitten in der
zweiten welle eine so hohe fallzahl
haben dann wäre das natürlich eine
katastrophe war dann würden wir in
dieser phase ii bei das ist so ähnlich
wie wenn ich ein feuer habe und gehst du
dann noch einmal wenn es ihn nach so
muss man sich das ungefähr vorstellen
damit würde das eine was wert hat sich
ja eine katastrophe wenn es aber etwas
später kommt wenn wir das feuer schon
gelöscht haben sind von diesen hohen
zahlen darunter dann ist auch eine
solche variante nicht so gefährlich über
den sieg stellte
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren